joe biden promised to deliver 100
million vaccine doses
into the arms of americans in a hundred
days and
we are i am thrilled to say on track to
dramatically
surpass that and at the same time we are
seeing coronavirus cases continue to
decline
uh very quickly faster than than many
people expected so let's
run through the numbers then i have
other covet updates we did this
each of the last few weeks i didn't
think that many people would would
actually
like this but it turns out a lot of
people aren't following the day-to-day
of what's going on with the virus
understandably and a ton of people wrote
in saying
actually the summaries are useful in
terms of where we are so let's jump
right in with one disclaimer
i'm going to give a lot of optimistic
news in this segment
it should not be used to encourage us
to stop being careful the optimistic
news should tell us let's keep
being careful not go crazy and if we do
that then there is hopefully a light at
the end of the tunnel
and yes i will address the variance of
course all right so let's start with
cases coronavirus cases on
average peaked on january 11th
at about 255 000 cases per day an insane
number
the good news is that since that peak
cases have declined
a whopping 64 where we are now averaging
92 000 cases per day now this is all
perspective
at one point a year ago when dr fauci
said
not a year ago eight months ago seven
months ago when dr fauci said
if we aren't careful we could
get up to a hundred thousand cases per
day in the fall and a whole bunch of
people said that's impossible
and of course dr fauci was right we
weren't careful and we actually got not
to 100
000 cases a day not to two hundred
thousand cases a day we actually had
three hundred three hundred thousand
cases
a day uh we had three hundred thousand
cases on one day
uh in the fall we are now back down
to ninety two thousand cases per day but
what matters is the rate of decline
down 64 in just 35 days you love to see
it
let's keep it going now in the meantime
deaths
which lag cases by three to four weeks
are finally starting to come down
peaking at an average of about
3 500 deaths a day in the united states
more 20 percent more than a 911 a day
now down 25
to a daily average of about 2 600 deaths
per day
still an unconscionable horrifying
number but we are seeing the improvement
and the improvement in deaths should
track the decline in cases as well
with about a three to four week lag now
to vaccination
joe biden promised a million doses a day
the us is now exceeding that by a full
two thirds with one and two-thirds
million vaccine doses per day going into
people's arms
with again new record days this weekend
2.2 million doses administered on
saturday
2.2 million doses administered on
sunday these are fantastic numbers
but they are not enough because at the
current rates
we wouldn't hit 50 percent immunity
until june 28th
we wouldn't reach 70 immunity a key
number
until september 5th so as i've said
before i didn't come up with this
medical experts did
the ideal would be to get to 3.5 million
doses per day
that would dramatically accelerate our
progress it's not impossible that we
would get there with a third vaccine
and hopefully with a fourth vaccine now
let's talk about vaccines and variants
once again we continue to learn more and
more about this
we have two vaccines currently in use in
the united states the moderna vaccine
and the pfizer
vaccine these are both two dose vaccines
with moderna
you have 28 days between doses with
pfizer you have 21 days
between doses okay we are close to
approval
for a third vaccine the johnson johnson
vaccine that is a one
dose vaccine that will dramatically
simplify logistics and
could get us could get us to 2.53
million vaccines a day
regularly fourth vaccine has the
possibility of getting us to three and a
half million
vaccines a day meanwhile what we know
about the effectiveness of these
vaccines is stunning it
it's not a miracle it's science so i
don't want to use the word miracle
but the numbers appear almost miraculous
israel
has done an incredible job with
vaccination they're already vaccinating
younger people
and uh the deal they made with pfizer is
that they will open up their data
so pfizer can get more information about
how the vaccine works in reality
one study of the vaccinated israeli
population
found that in the real world the vaccine
has 94 percent efficacy at preventing
symptomatic disease and a 92
drop in severe disease listen to these
numbers
a study of 525 000 vaccinated israelis
found
only 500 of them got the virus
that's 0.1
525 000 people 500 get the virus with
the vaccine
um and that was including some of them
got it between doses they weren't yet at
full immunity
of the 500 people that got the virus
four of the 500 had what you would call
a serious case
four and none of them died
these are incredible incredible numbers
the vaccine appears to be as good
in real life as it was in the phase
three trials
now it's not all great news we are
in a fight against these variants that
are spreading
the good news in that fight is that the
moderna and pfizer vaccines
appear really effective against the uk
variant
and the brazilian variant and they
appear less
but still quite effective against the
south
south africa variant it's just a matter
of speed
the faster we vaccinate the more we
prevent mutation
the more we prevent the spread of the
variants
which are slightly
stronger against the vaccine if you
imagine the variance in a fight against
the vaccines and the more
we can control this so if we can keep
this going
we are going to have a very different
situation statistically in the united
states by april 1st
and again a different situation by may
1st if we can get
beyond one and two-thirds million
vaccines a day if we can get to 2.5
steady or three we are looking at moving
up
the date at which 70 of the country will
be vaccinated from early september
into august possibly even into july
or according to some models even late
june if we can really quickly ramp up
vaccinations so let's keep tracking
numbers
the milestone i'm next looking for is
when we get under
50 000 cases per day that might only be
weeks away
if we can keep going it could be longer
we will soon see
and fortunately vaccine hesitancy
i won't dive into that a lot now because
we did that last week
vaccine hesitancy also continues to go
down
all good things we are hoping also
for approval on the vaccination of uh
kids um you know 10 12
14 years old by early summer
optimistically and that will also be a
big factor so a lot of good things
happening
not the time to go crazy not the time to
go crazy
light at the end of the tunnel we see it
if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief history of time of
course
by the great stephen hawking this is a
book that i have been aware of for so
long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video